when Disney Animation makes a movie
believe it or not like academics they do
research first they were looking for a
robot that was different from all robots
you've seen the movies like The
Terminator or the transformer and at the
time we were building inflatable arms we
were interested in arms with no bones
whatsoever so essentially balloon like
arms clearly an inflatable balloon like
robot gives them a completely different
look what we're trying to do with soft
robotics is find a way to use technology
to help people in particular people with
disabilities and older adults you're
going to help people do things like comb
their hair or brush their teeth or feed
them or or dress them or undress them or
clean them there's just no way you can
get a big heavy robot up close to
someone safely most people think of
robots either is tools for industry or
military things but when you say our
robot is going to help you be your
servant or take care of you that's a
stretch for most people so I think one
of the messages of this movie is going
to very clearly say there is a role for
robots to help people one of the
problems right now with existing
technologies what do you think about
electronics when you think about sensors
motors a lot of the machines that you
see in the commercial devices they're
made out of really rigid materials
materials that are completely on the
opposite end of the spectrum when it
comes to how rigid and elastic they are
compared to natural biological tissue
when you talk about actual physical
contact with a person you have to be
really careful with the types of
materials that we use you want to use
materials that are safe for contact um
they aren't going to be uncomfortable
and say if you kind of know where them
say in a globe or some kind of robotic
clothing or assistive device and they
also have to preserve our natural
function so in my lab we are developing
different types of sensors and actuators
and robots using soft materials were
like highly stretch up and deform
a trip we make very small micro channels
inside and then this micro channel is
filled with looked at meta or some other
liquid conductor the application could
give you can wear this material in your
body so you move around the you detect
the battery key detector how most you
are moving in if there's any contact
made on your body we really wanna focus
on developing new types of robotic arm
or systems we using soft materials and
flexible material that increases human
safety so what when I was I've been
developing here the lab is a hybrid for
a lot that then merges elements of
conventional riches robots and soft
robots
so for example we have like a very
lightweight internal skeleton so it's
rigid and make sure that the arm only
moves in ways we wanted to but it's very
very lightweight save it as bump
something it doesn't have the movements
of to cause any damage or any harm most
people have no idea what a soft robot is
and I think everybody will in a few
weeks and that's going to be a huge
change for our field